من امام المفوضيه الاوروبيه في بروكسل
مراسل الجزيره عبد الله الشامي طبعا حرص
وزراء الخارجيه الاوروبيين على الذهاب
لكيف لابداء دعم الكامل ماذا يمكنك ان
تخبرنا اكثر عن هذا الاجتماع فيك عبد الله
نعم عثمان هو اجتماع تضامني رمزي لا يتوقع
ان تكون او يخرج بقرارات بالنظر الى ان
هناك اجتماع رسميه سيكون في خلال اسبوعين
من الان في لوكسمبورج الاجتماع الاعتيادي
لكن كما سمعنا في كلمات كافه الوزراء بلا
استثناء واجتماع تضامني يراد منه ايصال
رسائل من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي لكيف بانها
لن تكون وحيده كما قال جوزيف
الخارجيه او كما قال ايضا الوزراء
كما قالوا لا تاخذ حربها فقط وانما تخوض
حربا بالنيابه عن اوروبا وعن القيم التي
قالوا انهم يقومون يعني التشارك مع
اوكرانيا فيها هذا الاجتماع بالطبع هو
اجتماع غير رسمي لكنه في ذات الوقت له
دلالات في التوقيت يسبق اجتماع القمه
الاوروبيه والمجتمع السياسي الاوروبي الذي
يضم اوكرانيا بعد يومين من الان في مدينه
غرناطه الاسبانيه ويتوقع ان يكون هناك
حديث حول تسريع عمليه انضمام اوكرانيا الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي عدد من الدول التي تشارك
اليوم خصوصا دول شرق ووسط اوروبا صرحوا
وزاره خارجيتها بانهم يريدون ان يكون هناك
بدء لعمليه الانضمام الرسمي الى كياب قبل
نهايه العام وبالتالي هناك حشد على ما
يبدو من ناحيه الاوكرانيين لكي تكون هناك
عمليه تسريع في هذا السياق ايضا الدعم
العسكري الاوكراني يطالبون بتسريع تسليم
طائرات 16 وكذلك ايضا الانتهاء من تدريب
الجنود او الطيارين الاوكرانيين على هذا
الامر وهو ما قالت وزيره خارجه هولندا
انهم يقومون به في هذه الاثناء بشكل عام
هو اجتماع لا ينتظر ربما ان يخرج بقرارات
لكنه بلا شك واجتماع تاريخي وله دلالات
عديده لم يعقد من قبل اجتماع الوزراء
خارجي في دوله خارج الاتحاد وبالتالي هي
رسائل عديده يريد الاوروبيون بها ان يطمئن
على ما يبدو انه رغم طول مده هذه الحرب
التي تدخل بعد عدد اشهر عامها الثالث الا
انه على ما يبدو لن يكون هناك تراجع باي
حال من الاحوال لهذا الدعم الاوروبي سواء
في حجمه او فيما يتوقع من بخصوص عضويه
اوكرانيا في الاتحاد
شكرا جزيلا من بروكسل عبد الله الشامي